hey everybody welcome to nerd wars I'm
Fatih and I'm Jeff we decided to do one
topical it's Harry Potter versus dr.
stray and I'll be arguing Harry Potter
I'll be arguing Doctor Strange Harry
Potter is it's real is real
they got wand and you go to London and
you go down the little alley and then
you can go right into what and buying
you know what everything supplies I've
been the Hogwarts it's awesome Harry
Potter's villains are all teachers dr.
strange has a doctor his villains are
not teachers who are his village
Voldemort is not a teacher never was a
Hogwarts teacher let's try a Hogwarts
student Oh
bernd fact win Jeff you know and don't
wear horses over Baltimore Baltimore
superpowers having no nose how was that
a superpower it's not a superpower and
that was an interpretation of the book
you know Jeff yes you should be arguing
for dr. strange because you have the
same gay facial hair that he does which
is why dr. strange would win right
Beverly our only argument is this
patient we are so awesome because I win
all these nerd wars everyone owes that
win the nerd war that when the world
otter doesn't even have magical powers
yes he does he has crappy magic you know
explorative you know low common fighting
ball Doctor Strange has traveled through
time traveled through the cosmos goes
traveling through time do for you
nothing you actually got to be able to
do something know you've done no crap go
back in time time and kill JK Rowling's
I just read that all right freakin
spider-man comic book where he took
spider-man back in time yeah how's it go
prevent something and you know who did
all the work spider-man cuz Doctor
Strange is lame no Polly good news right
just smart guy just like a teleportation
device that's all he's good for I do the
work when you could have some schmuck do
it for you cuz talking to you Peter
Harry Potter knows like seven spells
alright dr. Sarah you need those five
million even refuses to use them because
he's a lazy schmuck I'm okay you're
telling me you're telling me right now
that young a fight a young man a
seventeen year old and a 35 year old
you're gonna put your money on the 17
year old that fight yes you're stupid
he's limber he's limber but he's weak
he's on every little turd Herod I hate
there is a powerful magician of all time
then he's protected with the little
lightning dr. strange can't can't beat a
lightning scarf you know you know why
you know why has that ever happened in
the Marvel Universe a lightning scar and
Doctor Strange ever encountered a little
boy with the lightnings yeah yeah he
actually did know one you're just making
this you know why because Harry Potter's
ripped off of an old comic book I don't
remember the name of the comic book I'd
like you guys to tell us in these
comments you can leave it in the comment
wizard little boy with a lightning bolt
and a pet owl all right it's a comic
book she stole the idea a homeless woman
stole an idea from a comic book and all
of a sudden we're all paying millions of
dollars all right that's called a scam
I'm so gonna see the movie this weekend
just okay smart I'm gonna tell how
awesome it is here's the thing here's
like I don't need to watch like eight
movies watching these kids go through
puberty yes you do it's just yes for you
you know come on don't tell me you
wouldn't tap Hermione I will tell you
I'm not I have 90 wood in wive years in
five years called me up Hermione Granger
I don't know it Ron cuz he likes the
gingers no Ron I think's a teen now so
yes
all right that's nerd boys this fella
say you think we're doing what doctors
dr. strecher strange is not gonna win
but tell us who you think would win God
both suggestions
thanks so much for watching guys we want
to know who you think would win the next
nerd wars it's gonna be John McClane
from die hard versus Indiana Jones put
it in the comments the more interesting
and intriguing the more likely it will
be to end up in the video will showcase
it post video responses if you want we
also are gonna be taking the nerd war
suggestions from face book back again
rib comm so make sure to join the link
is in the underbar and we asked our
users who would be best of all the
magicians warlocks and wizards in the
world and here's what everyone said
[Music]